PROFESSOR: This also solves the
exchange degeneracy problem.
It kind of seems clear
that it solves it.
But since we made
such a fuss about it,
let's see it in more detail.
So in what sense it solves it?
It solves it in the
sense that you basically
don't get degeneracy once
you have this postulate.
Before this postulate,
for example,
you had the two electron state.
You said, well, it could be
this, or it could be that.
And which should I choose?
If they're equivalent,
we get into mistakes.
So which one is the state
of the two electrons?
Now we seem to have an answer.
It's the antisymmetric
combination.
The last part of the
answer is to say, well,
there should be just one
antisymmetric combination.
And when you have two
particles, it's kind of obvious.
But if you have more,
you can think a little.
And you will conclude that
it's kind of obvious as well.
But let's just check it.
So this would be
comment number 5,
which is solving the
exchange degeneracy problem.
So this is the way we solve
this problem, we discuss it.
Suppose we have a state u
that belongs to V tensor N.
Now I should be a little tongue
tied when I say this thing,
a state u belonging to this.
This is not a physical state.
We already declared that
arbitrary states in V N
are not physical states.
What should they call this?
Maybe a mathematical state or
a state, and then the others,
call them physical states.
You get the point.
Assume you have this
u that belongs here.
Then you can define V u,
a vector space associated
with u, which is
the span, all you
get by applying permutations,
the span of P alpha u for all P
alpha in the permutation
group S N. You see,
that was the idea of
the degeneracy exchange.
You got one state.
And you produce all these
other ones by permutation.
And then you don't
know which one to use.
So we're going back
to that situation.
You have one state.
You produce all you
can by perturbations.
And now you've got
a big vector space.
And which one to use?
Well, you know that you should
use the states that are totally
symmetric or antisymmetric.
But let's first
just get the idea
clear of what we have here.
Notice, that depending
on u, which u you choose,
this vector space may be
1-dimensional, 2-dimensional,,
3-dimensional, very
large dimension.
Could be of arbitrarily high
dimension, up to n factorial.
So let's take an example.
Suppose u is the state a
a b with tensor N equal 3.
And you choose this.
Well, if you apply
permutation operators,
you can also get
the state b a a.
You flip the first
and the third.
Or you can get a b a.
And that's it.
So in this case, you get three
states in V u, for example.
And here is the claim.
The claim is that
there's just one
state that is symmetric in V u.
Up claim, up to
scale V u contains
at most a single ket in Sym N
V and a single ket in Anti N V.
That is the claim that we
have solved the problem.
Now there's one state.
You produce the whole list
of states by permutation.
There's just one.
I said at most, because
sometimes in the case of Anti--
I should say here
actually, up the scale
V u contains a single ket and at
most a single ket in Anti N V.
For example, the one we
did up there, that example.
If you wanted to produce a
totally antisymmetric state,
you would not be able to do
it because of the a here.
You cannot and antisymmetrize
with states a and a.
If you have a state
of three fermions,
they must each be different.
And then you antisymmetrize.
You cannot antisymmetrize
states that are the same.
So that's the statement here.
Let's say a couple
of words about it.
So the first thing we can say
is that, yes, this is clear.
You can get a state
in Sym N V by doing
the symmetrizer acting in u.
So it's clear you
can get one state.
And you can get a
state in Anti N on V
by applying the
antisymmetrizer on u.
And you know.
You can get those
states directly.
Now, it may happen
that Anti of V
vanishes, because in
Anti, when you apply a,
you have some permutations
with plus, some with minus,
and there could
be a cancellation.
In this case, there
would be a cancellation.
In the symmetrize case,
there's no cancellation .
Possible So we'll see that.
So here it is.
The argument for not getting
more is kind of simple.
Let me go through it.
It's almost kind of obvious.
You could say, OK, I got one
state applying the projector.
So that's it, there's one state.
Well, you could say,
well, maybe somebody
hands you another state.
And then you would claim, oh,
it must be the same as this one.
So let's see that
that is the case.
Suppose psi is also in Sym
N V and belongs to V u.
So it would be a claim that
there's another state that
is symmetric.
So since it belongs
to V u, psi would
be the sum of C alphas
times P alphas on u.
What was V u was the
span of this state.
So if it's in that
vector space, it
would have to be in that space.
But since psi is
symmetric, psi is also
equal to S psi by
assumption or S
acting on C alpha P
alpha u, which is psi.
But the S comes in and
multiplies the P alpha.
And you'll recall that S times
P alpha is S. So you get this.
How nice.
If you get that, this is a state
that this independent of alpha.
So you get it out
here, S u times
sum over alpha of C alpha.
So what have you proven?
If you hand out
another state that you
claim is in the
symmetric subspace,
it is proportional to the one
you obtain with the projector.
There's no other
state you can find.
You're done with these things.
So I want to make
yet another comment,
comment 6 and comment
7, and we'll be done.
Comment 6 is a
construction for fermions.
It's a famous construction.
6, for fermions,
suppose you have
a state u this time,
which is phi on 1,
chi on the second, and
omega on the third.
This time, we have to build
an antisymmetric state.
So the state A on u, the
antisymmetric projector,
ti is 1 over 6 sum over alpha
E alpha times the permutation P
alpha acting on this state.
So this will be a sum
of six terms in which
this these states are
scrambled, sometimes with pluses
and sometimes with minuses.
There is a nice construction
in mathematics that does that.
Moreover, you find that if
you have two states that are
the same, if phi
would be equal to chi,
you cannot antisymmetrize here.
You will get 0.
This is kind of like a
statement that the two columns
of a matrix have 0
determinant if they're
proportional to each other.
So the claim is that
this construction
is nothing else than
1 over 3 factorial,
the following determinant in
which the three states are
written like that, phi,
chi, omega, phi, chi, omega,
and phi, chi, omega
into the determinant.
And then you'll put 1, 2,
3, 1, 2, 3, and 1, 2, 3.
The determinant of the
states written in that way--
I would recommend any
one to just write it out.
For three particles, you
have all the six elements.
Write them out.
Do the permutations.
And check that this
product produces that.
You know, for example,
that the determinant
will produce this product along
the diagonal with a plus sign,
this and that with a
plus sign, this and that
with a plus sign, then the
other ones with a minus
sign, but each one 3.
So for example,
this, this, that is
the one in which you have the
identity acting on the states.
And the reason this works
is the general formula.
I will put it in the notes.
But here, I think I don't
want to get into more of it.
It's a general formula
for determinants.
It's a well known formula.
If you have a
permutation P alpha,
remember permutation
P alpha, alpha
was supposed to be a list, alpha
of 1, alpha of 2, up to alpha
of n, which is a permutation
of the list 1, 1, up to n.
So if you have a matrix, the
determinant of a matrix B,
of any matrix, can be written
as the sum over permutations
of the sign of the
permutation times,
essentially, the
permutation acting
on the elements of the
matrix, that is B of alpha 1
1, B of alpha 2 2,
up to B of alpha n n.
This is like saying
in the matrix,
you will select
the alpha 1 element
from the first column,
the alpha 2 element
from the second column, all
of those, and multiply them.
And that's the determinant.
And that formula is the
reason this is true,
because this sum of
epsilons times Ps
really is the formula that
calculates the determinant.
You almost see the P here.
The P is the thing that took
the element 1, 1, to 2, 2
and and n, n and replaced
the 1 by alpha of 1, P of 2
and replaced them that way.
So I almost made the connection.
But we probably
need a few minutes
to make sure you
understand why it happened.
Last comment, seventh,
is occupation numbers.
If we're trying to describe
states in V tensor n,
and suppose you have a
state with n particles,
and that is V tensor n.
But suppose that this vector
space V has a basis of basis
vectors u 1, u 2,
up to u infinity.
It just goes on forever.
Then if you have
that, then there
is a way to think of all the
states that you can build.
And the way to think
of them is follows.
List the vectors here,
u 2 up to all those.
And you imagine that little n
1 particles are in this state.
Little n 2 particles
are in this state.
And it goes on like that.
So you write your state with
occupation numbers, n 1, n 2,
n 3.
And what is that state?
Well, there's n 1 of this one.
So u 1 for the first
particle up to u 1
for the and n 1 particle.
And then you have u 2 for the
next particle up to a u 2.
And you have n 2 of those.
And you have all the others.
And then you must apply into
it the symmetrization operator.
But this is the list of states.
This describes what you have.
Symmetrizing is a lot of work.
But listing the
occupation numbers
is really all there is
to it, because the rest
is a complicated algebraic
manipulation of symmetrization.
But now you know what
you must symmetrize.
You have n 1 times the state
1, n 2 times the state 2.
When you have fermions,
this is the same,
except that the n 1s, n
2s, n 3s can be 0 or 1.
And finally here, if it's
a state of n particles,
then and n 1 plus n 2 plus
all of those must add up to n,
because you have n particles.
So that brings us
to the end of 8.06.
Occupation numbers is where
quantum field theory begins.
You start constructing operators
that add particles and subtract
particles.
So it's a fitting place to end
your undergrad with quantum
mechanics education.
I wish you all the best.
I hope the course lived
up to your expectations.
It's an awesome
responsibility to teach
such an interesting course.
And we try to do it well.
And we wish that all of
you have enjoyed this
and have been motivated.
And many of you will understand
this subject, one day,
better than your teachers and
will help move it forward.
So take care.
Good luck.
And see you soon.
Bye.
[APPLAUSE]